ah
[Música]
a
la vacuna en brasilia es sinónimo de
pelea política en el estado de san pablo
el gobernador yo autor ya ha anunciado
que va a empezar a vacunar a la
población el 25 de enero inicialmente
nueve millones de personas dando la
preferencia a los sanitarios y a los
indígenas pero ha dejado claro que
cualquier brasileño que vaya a san paolo
será vacunado gratuitamente sus palabras
han sido interpretadas como un desafío a
jair bolsonaro el presidente del país
que está siendo criticado por la
lentitud con la que está organizando el
calendario de vacunación se sabe de
momento que a lo mejor va a empezar a
nivel federal en marzo también se sabe
que hay un acuerdo con la empresa facer
para comprar 70 millones de vacunas pero
también faltan jeringuillas y no hay
detalles sobre cómo va a ser el
calendario y la logística difícil de
esta vacunación hoy los gobernadores han
reunido en el palacio del planalto con
el ministro de sanidad para pedir que se
haga una acción conjunta y todo el mundo
quiere miedo de que brasil se va a
quedar a la cola del mundo y de américa
latina' a la hora de vacunar a su
población
[Música]
en una semana en la que la región
metropolitana de chile vuelve a vivir
restricciones para afinar en la lista de
contagios que se ha producido de kobe en
los últimos días las autoridades
chilenas confían en la llegada de dos
vacunas en el primer trimestre de 2021
para que si se vive una segunda ola en
el país no sea tan fuerte como las que
se hemos hemos visto en europa se
trataría de la vacuna china sinovac ha
comprometido 5 millones de dosis y por
otro lado facer que también se ha
comprometido a entregar 16 millones de
dosis en el primer trimestre en el país
y hay una vacuna que podrías recibir la
venia por parte del instituto de salud
pública esta misma semana en chile en
total serían 66 millones de dosis lo que
permitiría vacunar a 3,3 millones de
personas puesto que son necesarias dos
dosis por persona sin embargo las
autoridades chilenas contemplan el poder
vacunar a un total de un millón de
personas en el primer trimestre de 2021
sería el personal crítico es decir
trabajadores sanitarios personas a cargo
de recoger la basura fuerzas armadas
policía jardines personal a cargo de
jardines infantiles personas de la
tercera edad especialmente aquellos que
viven en residencias y también de
servicio nacional del menor
entre otros
[Música]
el gobierno de costa rica ha reservado
84 millones de dólares para comprar las
vacunas contra la cob y 19 hasta ahora
las autoridades han logrado tres
acuerdos para asegurar la vacunación de
tres millones de personas de un total de
cinco millones uno de los acuerdos es
con facer by gwen tech cuyo contrato se
firmó este 3 de diciembre y con el cual
se garantizan las dosis para cubrir a
1.5 millones de personas la adhesión de
costa rica a kóvacs facility un programa
de la oms se contempla una cobertura
poblacional de poco más de un millón de
personas y finalmente astrazéneca
suministraría un millón de dosis para
cubrir a 500 mil personas se espera que
la vacunación empiece en el primer
trimestre del año 2021 aunque todavía no
hay una fecha exacta porque falta
definir cuándo y cómo llegarán las
vacunas el ministerio de salud ha dicho
que las primeras personas en vacunarse
serán los miembros del personal
sanitario y quienes tengan condiciones
de riesgo ante el coronavirus unos 200
funcionarios se encargan de los
preparativos desde hace meses para esta
vacunación que de momento sería
únicamente administrada por el sistema
público
[Música]